what was the process of making the film
like did you know that you were making
this thing I was just special and
beautiful and [ __ ] wonderful in that
well I mean we tried to bring we tried I
tried to assemble a creative team and a
cast that was as good as I could being
somebody who I had no is the first movie
so I had no reputation to fall back on
no other work to show to get people
excited about working with is like I'm
just a guy so I did the best I could and
assembling these fantastic people and
got lucky that this particular group of
people fell into the orbit of this movie
it was completely accidental just the
movie gods kind of smiled that the movie
gods and robbery and as well we've got
our Robbie Reiser out there Robbie
Robbie is out there somewhere Robbie
read the most important black cast and
director in the history of cinema who is
responsible for everybody you know now
Robbie brought me
Lorenza Nia came to me from Hellena
lorenz from the studio and then Robbie
brought everybody else brought me Isaiah
and Bill and Lisa and Leonard and
Bernadette came to me in Chicago on they
were cast in Chicago by Jane Alderman
but Robbie brought through this middle
part of the cast right here that I would
not be if I was very fortunate to Robbie
decided catch it it's kind of cool
watching the movie it's kind of like
like this reunion of everybody who was
kind of like a part of this thing these
iconic faces and I forgot how so many of
the scenes are these eight characters
and you cut to a reaction you just get
so much life again as I heard in the
auditorium all this life given from all
these faces up here but I want to talk
to uh lorenz first because I read this
article that you know when the financing
came together it was contingent upon you
in a certain way and when I was doing
the research I looked back and I was
like oh yeah I went from oh dog to
Darius and in it again I will walk in
the center would be like that ain't no
dog you know but but clearly it was so
talked to me about you know the script
coming to you and and where you were in
your career at that point and what it
was like just stuff into this character
Ted do you want to you want
my version of you your version and our
correct you choose where I'll say he's
gotten very honest appear go Lorenzo
tell your version what had you correct
me no um yeah I guess that the studio
was pretty interested in working with me
I had done minister society he's still
auditioned sorry Ida
alright okay audition kind of true
um however it was I'm just very
fortunate to been next to miss neele on
audition testing whatever it was laid
out as but all the audition at that
level you call the screen test screen
test okay oh my yeah I'm although this
and I I'll still I will screen test with
you right now me to it
part two part two screen tested no um
listen when the script came to me you
know I'm always looking for new
challenges and something that would be
different and over my career as I look
back you know I don't typically have
like sort of a a one kind of movie that
you know that I gravitate towards
different roles I don't have the same
move if you will and this was something
that I thought would be kind of cool I
love the idea that these people spoke
differently to each other I love the
idea that you know it was romantic and
at the same time it was it was going to
be in Chicago and we hadn't really seen
anything and my hometown quite liked it
so I was able to get a chance to spend
some time with with Ted I want to have a
meeting of the minds he's from Chicago
and we had to sort of different points
of views about who Darius was but as I
got to know him and to really commit to
what the journey would be you know
every step of the way you know I'm
always here and I had tit-for-tat but
I'm very appreciative to him open me
opening me up in my mind to a character
that I hadn't played before you know
there were things that I sometimes I
would be a little resistant about the
vulnerability I think is the thing that
I was fighting against
and I wasn't used to characters being as
vulnerable as Darius and I think it was
important to show us as men being
vulnerable and I thank you for that but
that was my biggest tug of war wasn't
about women and all that other stuff it
really was about just being vulnerable
and as I look back on it and as I am in
my own personal life how vulnerable you
know I can be I think it was really
really important for us for the world to
see him for the culture so thank you how
you doing I'm good how are you I'm good
I want to hear a woman's perspective on
what it was like to make this film
because so much of it hinges on the
relationship between the two of you are
both the story that's being told but
also the way y'all look at one another
so what was it like for you to step into
this park because it was different for
you at this time in your career as well
I mean I was relatively still very new
to the business and I hadn't proven
myself to be able to open a movie and it
didn't open so big but thank God now you
guys have all followed us and it's
become a cult classic and you know the
met that I always say that this film was
before its time
black people were so excited to see
ourselves like this but I think when the
film was released because we hadn't
because there was no formal aook process
to follow it sort of got lost as this
hidden gem and I'm okay with that you
know why because we're all here today
celebrating and that to me when you have
staying power and the story is relevant
and we are able to give our
sells permission to show black love on
film then I feel like I did my job yes
and had the movie done here agent we
probably wouldn't be sitting here right
now yeah you know it's true and but but
also for me I am I read the script and I
thought wow this is amazing I'm from
Brooklyn my father is a poet my mother
is a fine artist
so this world was very familiar to me
and when I look back on on all the women
that I've played in this in this
beautiful career and these wonderful
opportunities
Nina is probably the most like myself
and so when I couldn't sit through the
movie I was going to cry like literally
because it touches me in such a deep way
and the only disappointment I have is
that we have not seen a film like this
since
[Applause]